visited Eve hello I'm Lucy James I am
joined here by rob crossley hello Rob
hello and i recently got to play
resident evil HD so this is the
remastered HD shiny version but not of
the 1996 original games okay so the game
was remastered remade for the Gamecube
in 2002 so this is a nice and shiny new
version of that it's a remaster of a
remake of an original pretty much yes
but you can see so the original version
the ps1 version we had a little look
before we started recording this how do
you know like live-action people doing
this cutscene um which looked incredible
but now we have you know proper video
game people yes I've gone from live
action's actual filming to cg stuff and
I remember when the would actually
playing the ps1 version and it was kind
of like it was amazing to see like
actual footage inside a video okay so
they've kind of gone back a step from
that with just you know instead ding cg
right yeah I guess so um and so I played
this game probably for about an hour and
a half um so this is the obviously the
opening cutscene looks quite nice I pay
for now and a half and it is really a
very kind of straight I'm I'm more used
to the the modern resident evil so this
is a very weird mix of old and new right
um because you still have the fixed
camera angles from the original um which
if you're not used to those it makes
life really quite difficult especially
when you first encounter a few zombies
and luckily because I edited this video
I've made it so I look really good ok so
what bits did you not put in the video
my first encounter when I couldn't
figure out that so right trigger I
thought was shoot like in every game
ever it's not his map right so I managed
to get rid of like a whole chunk of that
so it's right it's a kind of strange mix
between olden you um but obviously the
more you play it the more you get used
to it and I guess because we still have
the build in the office when you play
it'll be like kind of going
of course yeah but although the
decoration is a bit better this time
yeah sure and so here's our first look
at the famous carnivorous dogs and so
there is Jill so I played his Jill don't
my playthrough who do you normally pick
I normally picture as well actually hmm
um so I did notice that jill has jiggle
physics yeah right I don't actually
remember that no I played this when I
was like 13 years old so I should
remember that oh yeah I I should never
forget that but yeah so she has how how
did that feel was a bit awkward you know
what it's they're not dead or alive
levels right so it's not so bad it's
kind of forgivable jiggle physics
forgivable [ __ ] foolish oh dear um so
what kind of coming and this is the this
bravoteens helicopter coming in so who's
that that's Chris Redfield right i mean
yeah he kind of looks like he's all
those Wesker see that's the very first
time we've seen Wesker right Oh
legendary character in the series yeah
this is his introduction and he's kind
of about us yeah he's like awesome
throughout the entire series and there
is the infrastructure if you're being
chased by a pack of dogs would you run
into a haunted mansion always yeah
always especially when it looks om to
the survival horror so what's really
cool is they have this mix of obviously
the famous loading screens which were
the opening doors they've left those in
and if you go back and look at the
original and you know especially the
original mansion and how blocky it was
and I mean it was nineteen ninety-six
obviously but the difference is kind of
astounding it looks great yeah I'm just
comparing this to the PlayStation
original I mean you know it was stark by
comparison there was a much detail there
wasn't much furniture or anything and
this is I'm just it's actually quite an
improvement on the gamecube version
right so this is where my handy editing
comes in Oh comes in use so this is the
famous zombie turn around okay if you're
not convinced as a zombie yeah yeah
oh here we go there it is used to go to
a dentist see see that again a lovely
cut where it makes me look like an
absolute badass um so how did the
controls feel at this point because
obviously now that you're moving moving
around the mansion you do like hard
camera cuts right oh my yes right so
interestingly so I more familiar with
them or was the more modern resident
evil so you know 4 onwards I would say
and especially six what think the
biggest thing I found is it six is very
very hand holdy it's like button prompts
everywhere and all this kind of stuff
true and so then going back to the
original even this is a remake it just
feels like I don't know what I'm doing
because there's no prompts telling me
you know to open a door or something
because in in modern games if a prompt
immediately doesn't come up you assume
that no this doors locked you can't get
past favor isn't evil that's not the
case except it's probably locked so with
the controls i recall correctly you
press up to move in the direction that
the / the character is facing right yes
but that gets confusing when the the
camera obviously card cuts and you know
you seem to be facing a different
direction so this a little bit here um
obviously some of the puzzle elements
were just already cool so getting a
getting an arrow that I found in the
mansion and sort of taking it apart and
then using it to get into this area and
getting this book of curses thanks to
delicately on the table 1 i've got to
tell you it took me a depressing amount
of time surprisingly long amount of time
to realize there was a key on it oh um
because of course obvious it's all about
example about that yes you have to
inspect the items which is actually a
really cool element all right oh yes the
the famous dog through the window
shooting floor haha I hit it I hit it so
in the gamecube version they kind of put
in this defensive weapon version this
defends a weapon thing so if you got
attacked you in the ps1 version you'd be
pretty screwed and gamecube version on
words you could equip a defensive weapon
i think that you can only use once and
so Jill and Chris can both use a dagger
um but then later on Jill gets this kind
of stun gun nothing and a yoga taser and
Chris gets a stun grenade that you can
like shoving a mouth of the zombie I'm
just quite cool so there's another
little loading screen which I thought
tonight I thought so nice to kind of
build to the tension as well yeah it's
not much the original and yeah
absolutely agree with you on on building
attention so this is one of the safe
rooms right yes it was a calming
presence to the safe rooms isn't there
yeah and I mean that's something that um
Shinji Mikami is used in the evil win as
well have you seen so the safe rooms
kind of play this like classical music
and it feels safe but you kind of know
that it that it's not and so obviously
you have a very limited amount of things
you can carry this is me kind of messing
around and depositing things that I
probably should have kept this is quite
cool so I left this bit in especially
because it's just I mean at this point I
was getting quite rattled because I was
trying to get a very specific thing oh
right oh I remember this now yeah of
course how could I forget it's just yeah
the slow walk which is really cool so
are we do defining these are zombies the
undead well that's the thing even
resident evil changes Oh yep once more
just to make sure of course cuz I have
to reserve your ammo in this game just
before right of course and then yeah
there's another guy oh I try to examine
him nothing there cuz normally you'd
have something pop up let's say you know
check out what this guy's carrying I've
gotta say it does look absolute
beautiful dinner it's not a great job
toilet gonna need that in it in a second
yeah um could you remember this oh yeah
so it's quite nice to see what they've
done with all the kind of the famous big
scary moments of the game there are
still quite yeah there it is terrifying
even now
and see yet they love the coming around
the corner and seeing the kind of the
hard cart and you can't get away it's
all yeah it's great look badass down in
really [ __ ] love it no there's a oh
there's a famous airline in it this as
well could the jill sandwich right tell
us about that so the jill sandwich is a
terrible line of dialogue from the
original game where it occurs after this
cutscene so i painstakingly went through
to find it so Jill's caught in a room
the ceilings coming down Barry's coming
to savor let's watch this play out
because the jill sandwich is iconic
Barry that was a close one a second late
you would have fit nicely into a
sandwich really wait admittedly it's no
you were almost to jill sandwich um
because this is a remake of the gamecube
version so sadly they did redo the
dialogue but it's still a pretty great
line absolutely so the HD version of
resident evil is coming out on ps3 ps4
xbox 360 xbox one and pc at some point
in 2015 so for milan resident evil make
sure you keep your eye on gamespot